et puis le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste est revenu sur l' affaire des
diamants de bokassa il a voulu prendre
une certaine hauteur mais a refusé le
principe invoqué par certains de la
raison d'état
je dis et je répète que pour les
socialistes il n'y a pas de raison
d'état et que tout homme public y
compris bien entendu le plus important
d'entre eux doit être en mesure à tout
moment d'expliquer les de s'expliquer
sans que l'on préjuge en quoi que ce
soit approbation condamnation il n'y a
pas de raison d'état il y a le
déplorable processus de la politique
franco centrafricaine
la triste compromissions de la france
dans la dictature de bokassa il y a
l'étrange et maladroite intervention de
la france dans les affaires intérieures
de centrafrique au cours de ces
dernières semaines et il y a par voie de
conséquence une situation particulière
du président la république et des
gouvernants français qui se sont laissés
entraîner puisque il convenait dans des
relations de caractère personnel qui se
trouve à l'origine de la question que
vous me posez côté comme unique